let's go next to haman from boston
haman you're on the air uh hello david
can you hear me yes i can
oh amazing uh so a long time listener
first time caller here um
i wanted to get your thoughts on biden's
approach to the iran deal
i think that has been very uh
disappointing because when he was
campaigning he um
promised to get the us back into the
iran deal right like um relatively
quickly and then
his approach now seems to be um a little
bit more aggressive he's demanding that
iran get back into the deal first before
um the us gets back into the deal and
that doesn't really make a lot of sense
to me because
u.s was the first one um to pull out of
the deal
so it feels like um he should be uh you
know approaching iran
in a more uh friendly manner yeah i mean
i think i
i agree with you that the approach he's
taking is not particularly likely to
work
uh at the same time i think that it
would meet
it would be illogical for biden to get
back in without
iran at least being in compliance and we
have reason to believe now that iran is
out of compliance now as i've said
before
of course they're out of compliance once
donald trump pulled out of the deal
iran's best strategic move is to start
restart the nuclear research so that
then they have something to negotiate
with in the future so unfortunately joe
biden is now in a situation
where he has to clean up a mess that was
caused by donald trump iran was
in compliance trump just didn't like the
deal or he didn't like obama so he said
i'm going to get out of the deal
and iran naturally went out of
compliance the the problem for joe biden
now is
on the one hand as you point out it was
the us who just bailed
so in it is sort of the responsibility
of the us to get back in
at the same time the us can't get back
in if iran
isn't in compliance so what's the what's
the bridge the bridge might be
that they negotiate something where iran
agrees to be in compliance by a certain
period of time
so iran might say let's all come back to
the table and redo the deal
give us six months or 12 months to get
back into compliance i'm just thinking
out loud here
but you're completely right that the way
it's going is not very likely to work
right and i also had another question uh
regarding the same issue
so is the decision to get back into the
deal
completely up to biden or does it does
that have to be like approved by
um by congress i don't believe it needs
congressional approval and maybe people
in in the audience will um be able to
wait i i don't believe
biden needs congressional approval to
get back in the deal
so that's something that he can uh
unilaterally just take care of
yeah i mean unilaterally it's not going
to happen just joe biden saying here's
what i'm doing in practice that's not
how it happens but it's not i don't i
don't believe it's subject to
congressional approval no
i see well um thank you so much for
taking my call david
my pleasure great to hear from you